hello and welcome to this video playing
boom ah yeah 0i love to that's not a
good squad don't quite remember how
those games went let's see now he tries
to play Hedgehog kind of physician let's
see yeah I think this should be okay
it's a little bit different to other
hedgehogs because of this early a six I
wonder if you can get in b6 or that all
that easy a couple of interesting
options here I'm going to I'm going to
go for this but not entirely sure about
it 194 try the wrecked Lee put in
putting pressure on the 60 directly
so okay Bishop c6 a half 95 but what is
a good plan in this position not quite
sure not quite sure is it's very solid
of course the sexy has protected quite
reliably something like f4 f5 could be
an option but it's not easy to get in
then after no I think maybe here queen
is not really that well placed on the
form
jfif 5 is something I mean he just sits
there and does nothing in the Hedgehog
this is often a good to practical
advantage that you have you can play
lots of moves without investing time and
still be quite okay but lucky is here I
mean this is quite okay for black this
position
you have the Queen trade it's not what I
originally wanted but I felt that
bringing a night to d4 isn't all that
bad maybe that also supports the later
half five yeah bishop age three and then
f5 is interesting i think and i'll try
that okay if you move the epod i'll be
able to use the d5 square it's not all
that easy though and okay if i go back
this definitely also be five check ya f
five feet can take the arcade going to
take you for I don't mind that much
not entirely sure about all this and
then download the clock yeah this is
this as possible you get to be five and
unless this is the thing if I have some
time it's cool but he gets to be five
hmm let's be five in and have to spend
some time here yeah we have to spend
some time to organize this position and
yeah maybe plate that well I think I'm
in some trouble here
now probably I should go for night XD
for set up against this against this
type of Hedgehog
I mean what you played this is a pretty
yeah pretty questionable line but I
didn't really didn't really care come
came close to any sort of reputation
with this cruel takes so just what to do
I'm definitely okay again
you know so I would just see not to lose
a pawn now
I guess I will win the a or D pawn
aiming aiming at high morning before
grah offered black resins okay I
wouldn't have taken the draw anyway I
mean this is scanning relatively quickly
and i can't play with musiah already
yeah I think probably quit legs before
isn't the best way of doing it this is a
somewhat second raid head shock because
he didn't really force any concessions
from me which is usually happening in
the normal move water maybe I should
really take with the night castles and
then you have the choice you can go
efore be three yeah probably better i
was thinking maybe with 24 i can get
some quick play against the d6 porn but
the way he played it i think showed that
I'm getting nowhere with this approach
not just drops back to e8 yeah I think
it's oops it's rather equal ish but but
then the way it went I think I got into
trouble around here I felt aqui em that
that this didn't go too well I'm not
sure about this f5 approach I wanted to
do something active the engine just
wants to take him i was thinking i can
just recapture why is that not working
Bishop g5 winning okay threatens g6 cell
which is a big threat my bishop is
hanging and this is boobs this is bad so
that was a big blunder than a can take
and here I also don't like this but here
I probably somewhat ok so here
and yeah after this I'm fine I'm fine I
mean am I think maybe I'm better because
I have those roxys six ideas and I
played a couple of moves that really
just they lost time and didn't have any
particular banner hood you know this
also loses time I just get get all the
moves in there one day I will win down
the the pawn on e4 as well yet here he
resigned which is of course a bit early
but ok i will get this i will get the
apron running it might still be that he
has some chances but it's tough to say
this is a winner like here go a for
something like this I mean this pawn
structure here is not exactly idea to
promote a pawn the engine wants to ditch
this and then get to get the porn going
can keep this
I'm not entirely sure if this is the
draw or win any pawn is pretty much
pretty far too on advanced I'm not
entirely sure that's a very close call
um it's not quite obvious how wide
should win that that's clear I mean I
can try to come around like that I can i
can give you a couple engine moves just
to see engine 10 h 5 ER well that's that
doesn't look all that exciting ok this
is what the engine wants to do man this
is probably a draw or is there I know
there are there are some there are
breakthrough with with e5 this is the
thing I am ok so here still if it puts
it here and now just stay is how am i
winning this yeah stockfish you say plus
3 but how am i winning I think the
computer doesn't get it
this is this is looking better so has to
stay here and then let something like a
50 sinuses here but he gets gets all the
pawns and this is the draw probably okay
well this is set up is also it is just
about the possible breakthrough but
other than that it doesn't make any
sense yeah tough to say I think it's
more likely a draw than a win for what
okay well thanks for watching